first of all the advertisement part
about Mayfield we do we do have to
advertise I mean it may be seem a little
strange that venture capitalists who
have all that money would be looking for
customers but in many ways we are
looking for good good good good teams
and good ideas Mayfield has been around
a long time we're one of the very early
venture firms founded in 1960 two years
ago in 1969 I guess I was about 69
actually the initial money was Stanford
money Tommy Davis had the idea of
working with Stanford to invest some of
their money in a high tech in the valley
and that was the founding of Mayfield we
currently have two point 1 billion under
management we're investing what's called
Mayfield 11 our 11th fund our limited
partners are mostly University endowment
funds and pension funds we have seven
investing partners I used to be called
general partners the lawyers told us we
should call ourselves managing directors
so we whenever the lawyers tell us to do
something we always do it of course
there's one venture partner in 3e IRS or
entrepreneurs or executives and
residents that that venture partner and
IRS come in and out as we need and find
additional help our focus is on
innovative information technology we
used to do biotech we don't anymore we
got out of it about five years ago still
have some companies in our portfolio in
that area but we decided to narrow our
focus and into the IT area there's you
know you can read the the numbers we do
early-stage Mayfield and one of things
you need to realize when you're going
out to pitch VCS as you pitch the right
VCS we are very focused on early stage
early means one or two people with a
bright idea
we'll do some B rounds which is you know
revenue a little bit you know some
progress but not fully developed you
need to raise money to go you know ramp
up the sales effort but we do relatively
few of those most of ours are either
seed incubation or a round first
institutional investors in we almost
always partner these days with another
firm we don't like to
it's just better in terms of getting
help on their on the with to the company
as well as spread the risk we are very
active last year and continue to be
active this year we did actually 13
deals total last year we had done 12 in
a prior two years so we doubled our pace
and we've done three in the last couple
months so and and the deal flow pace is
good entrepreneurs are coming out of
retirement I guess actually literally
we're seeing a lot of people who made a
lot of money in the bubble thought
they'd go buy the big boat retire and
got bored and are looking to do
something exciting again so there's
there's as well as probably young
Stanford graduates so how to get a VC to
pay attention unsolicited business plans
or emails rarely work I read I am the
screener of most of the unsolicited
plans that come in through the business
plans not at Mayfield com
we also each partner gets a fairly large
number of direct emails our way to our
email address is available on the on our
website and you can send an email a
business plan or an introductory summary
or whatever you're going to send
directly to a partner very few of these
ever we can't you know we've asked our
itself have we ever really funded a
totally unsolicited over the never heard
of the people never and it's hard to
find one it really is if probably there
might be one but nobody could remember
it so I'm not gonna say never but almost
never so where do they where do we find
out about deals the first place is
entrepreneurs and business associates
most of the referrals come to us from
people we know in bigger companies
smaller companies existing companies
used to be working in our existing
companies there are people we know are
where most of the introductions to
business opportunities come from other
venture capitalists again because we are
now networking much better than we did
in the bubble between VCS and many we
see a lot of deals referred by another
venture capitalist that sought is
interested in investing looking for a co
investor
even in an a round and they introduced
it to us in whist and just like we
introduced to them we do get deals out
of universities or research institutions
we've done a fair number of deals out of
Stanford we did MIPS and Silicon
Graphics and you know John Hennessy was
one of the cofounders of MIPS that may
feel funded we did a deal a couple years
ago t ran out of Stanford so we do look
at early-stage technology deals out of
Stanford and other universities were
involved with research institutions like
us RI we look at their early-stage
technology put a team together pull it
out on the company we've done nuance
voice recognition company was a public
company out of SR I Surgical was out of
SR I so we do look for other
opportunities other places to find
technology and there is a network of the
lawyers if you know if you absolutely
you know it's I feel like if you have if
you've been in this valley in a year and
can't stick your arms out and touch
somebody who knows us you haven't you've
been sitting in your your room not
getting out there there it's it's a
pretty wide network that we touch
particularly if you're in Stanford I
mean there is absolutely most of the
professor's know lots of VCS here you're
getting introductions should not be that
hard but if you don't know anybody and
even the lawyers a Wilson Sonsini will
take a look at what you got if they like
it introduce you to venture capitalists
to get us to pay attention you really
should learn something about the partner
I it's do not gonna send a business plan
or a summary to all of the partners in
that firm if you're really going to go
to or if you got somebody that's going
to reduce you find out which partner you
think is the best to target or to
partners go to our website our
backgrounds are there that companies are
on the board is true of all venture
capitalist companies they're on the
boards over there so find one or two
that you think would be of interest and
then find a way to get an introduction
through a professor through a former
entrepreneur that might know them find a
way to get an introduction
the ones that you think would be most
likely interested in the area that your
your you're proposing to do a plan in to
a business it so what do you send today
you know again it should be an
introduction it shouldn't be you see if
you can send an email to me saying I was
introduced to you by you know professor
Plummer he suggested I contact you
obviously we better flummery introduce
me you instead I got these great bright
students they're working on this you all
take a look at it but if he's too busy
or whatever at least use his name as
long as it gives you permission of
course
tell me about who you are why you think
you're especially qualified to be doing
this what the problem the products also
here this Steve from me over and over
and over again what problem do you solve
I want to know that up front and I want
to know that you understand what problem
you solved obviously what market it's in
I can pretty figure that out this is
what's in this summary of business
status where are you you two guys with a
bright idea in a garage are you you know
spend some of your own money orient
family and friends money and you know
you've out there and got a product at a
couple customer references where are you
and some kind of financial plan how much
money are you raising how much revenue
do you expect you know that kind of
thing it's money you need you think to
get to profitability this is the
executive summary it's a pen if you have
a presentation a copy of presentation
it's amazing to me I can't think of a
deal recently we funded it had a written
business plan and it actually irritates
me personally
then nobody does that anymore because I
think it's a good discipline but nobody
does it's literally an executive summary
in a PowerPoint these days okay
I happen to think having to write down a
20 page 15 20 page excuse me business
plan is a good discipline it helps you
think through so even if you only write
the business plan for yourself and then
produce a summary from it it's good
discipline I like to see them
my partner's don't seem to care as much
in most VCS don't seem to care as much
but I think it's good discipline to have
to write it down and you guys are if
you're in this school hopefully they're
teaching you what's in a business plan
so how do we decide what who to me it is
very much again based on who did the
introduction as I said if it's
unsolicited I never heard of you
unlikely if you said I heard you know if
if you send me a plan I heard you speak
at the GSB event would you take a look
I'll read it I read all of them it's fun
I mean I learned about more strange
technologies and ideas I mean one of the
my favorite like we kind of have a
little contest going my favorite is the
grow light it helps vegetables grow
bigger you know really big and this guy
wanted money to fund the development and
research on it because it turns out they
they're tasteless when they grow faster
and bigger I mean they did they had no
flavor or tasted horrible so his idea
was to raise money to improve the
quality of a taste but still have them
grow fast of course that's probably not
possible but that's okay
quality of the team is very important
you'll hear this theme over and over and
over again I can't emphasize it enough
who are the people today's world there
are you know it's not like the bubble
again I'll say this too many times
you've probably tired of hearing it
today we can get very very good
experienced teams in our companies you
don't have to have its a bright
technologist or two with a great idea
we'll put a team around you business
team but we need at least one passionate
entrepreneur around which we can build a
team deals where VCS kind of bring
together and hope for you know their
hard I want somebody that can you know
really attract talent in the core team
much much prefer that obviously is it an
area of investment interest if you if
you did your work well you you looked at
my you know our bio or the person you're
trying to pitch and you know they're
interested in it and you will not have
missed the area of technology and market
we're interested in although I am on the
board of a fiber optic company and I'm
not interested in any more of those so
there are some technology areas that are
a little bit out of favor right now
and stage again you've picked your
you've picked your VC to pitch based on
what kinds of companies at stage they're
in
important as well so I'll get a an email
with an introduction from somebody I
usually know or somebody who used to me
you know I've been in this valley in
multiple companies since 1971 so I know
a lot of people most of my deals come
from people who worked in a company or
for me in there in my prior life and
I'll always meet them I met one
yesterday I mean there's a young
engineer that worked for us for a number
of years and yeah I didn't gave him good
feedback on why I wouldn't fund him and
he said thank you very much
but I'll usually meet with anybody I
know if it's introduced or introduced by
somebody I respect you know I don't care
what you're doing the first meeting this
is the famous dreaded first meeting with
venture capitalists it's you we
scheduled we scheduled an hour I
scheduled an hour and a half on my
calendar zombie sees only the hour most
VCS come in late
I don't you should be on time because
they might come in on time don't be late
okay
we've had people late it's very
embarrassing come 15 minutes early just
don't tell me traffic was bad and all
that stuff at nine o'clock in the
morning I know it's bad don't be late
you will we will schedule an hour it's
always a PowerPoint we have a projector
we have overheads we have Ethernet
connection if you got a demo something
we have a wireless connections for your
PC but come early and bring your old
laptop with your pitch on it one of the
things is who should I bring comes up I
forgot to put that on here don't I mean
it depends if there's only two of you
bring two of you two co-founders so I
usually it's bring to bring the people
you think I'll impress me
don't bring every engineer that song you
know if there's five guys starting a
company and three of them are
programmers I don't need to see your
programmers I'm sure you got good
programmers but bring the people you
think will impress and don't bring them
to sit there and say nothing okay they
need to be part of the you know expected
questions or part of the pitch or
something you know it's it's just it's
weird to me when we have five guys show
up and one of them presents and the
other four sit there like lumps it
doesn't show well
are they or they do their introduction
we are judging the team as much as the
business in that first hour we are we
are absolutely judging that your ability
to articulate and be passionate about
what you're doing as much as we are the
technology
you
for yes it's absolutely critical that
you put the relevant I will emphasize
this the relevant experience in both the
executive summary you know not your
resume and when you introduce yourself
in at one hour I've had one group that
literally took the first 20 minutes of
the meeting to introduce themselves I
just I got to the point I couldn't sit
there anymore you know it was so painful
I can read you know flash up a resume I
can read it pretty quick or put it in a
package or but tell me what is relevant
that you've done that makes you
unbelievably qualified and unbelievably
impressive to be doing this don't tell
me your life story and the same with the
other team a night you engineers are the
worst at this yeah okay Jack tell it
tell them about your background well I
was born and you know New Mexico and
went to college and just doesn't matter
to me you know that's what have you done
it makes you particularly qualified
anywhere from none to reading the
executive summary and looking at the
pitch ahead of time almost you know mo
if I have time all out I wouldn't have
at I've at least read this summer eat
enough to invite you in okay I'm
interested although I have done deals
where again it was introduced by
somebody I trust have no idea what they
doing
I get the summary too late or the or the
pitch too late and I walk in cold so
what are you doing you should assume we
know nothing
you can ask by the way you know always I
as I was talking to guys ahead of this
this is selling and in good selling you
always qualify your audience ok so you
can qualify ahead of time you know if
any of you sold a big corporations you
go let's see let me understand this guy
on pitching what's his responsibility
who does your report to pitch NBC's you
can do some background checking then
when you come in you know have you how
much do you know about this have you
read it
you gonna ask
it is possible I would not do it in the
first meeting it's possible to do a web
conference and we've done them they're
not very effective so unless you really
need that if the see if the leader I'll
call on the CEO for talk doesn't have to
be the CEO but if the leader can't get
us interested in that first hour and
doesn't know the business well enough
and know the technology well enough to
pitch us and if I ask a deep technical
question that you can't answer say can
we come back to you on that in another
meeting would be better than having them
on a web conference in my opinion
usually yes absolutely that's knowing
your audience the other one is read your
audience and skip what they know I I
just I was in one pitch where my
partner's still teased me about this you
know I've been listening here for 30
minutes and I still don't know what you
do you know and I dig I just kept going
on and I'm you know I'm I can't you can
read me pretty well when I'm getting
bored it didn't hard you know or my
partners I mean we see a lot of these so
if you look at somebody you can tell if
they're interested in what you're
pitching and we read real well you know
any night I'm not reading you these
points I'm talking to you about them
don't read them to me okay
use your PowerPoint as a point to talk
to
you're selling the team you're selling
the idea you're selling your passion
you're selling you're selling everything
to get me to give you money I don't mean
some people in turn you know quit
selling with over selling okay don't get
caught in an over-exaggeration do not
tell me if you don't know something say
you don't know it and you'll find out or
if you don't you know do not get caught
you know in even close to an
exaggeration so I mean selling in the
enthusiasm I excuse one guy
CEO actually this was in a second round
of sell of presenting from an easy-chair
you know he'd come in and sit back in a
chair and kind of you know go through
the slides and it's like where is the
enthusiasm you know so it's stand-up you
know it's easy there we got we got real
comfortable chairs because we spend a
lot of time in them you know we don't
have them for you we haven't for us okay
so don't take advantage of our
comfortable chairs while you're pitching
you know you've always present better if
you stand up you know that do it
this is the kind of information again if
I was writing a business plan if I was
starting a company if I wanted to raise
money these are the things I'd be asking
myself as much as telling my potential
investors this is probably the most
important and we talked I if is is your
product a vitamin or a painkiller
what pain are you solving and today's
market is reluctant to most customers in
today's world are reluctant to buy from
startups the big corporations the big
communications service provider is the
big you know equipment companies that
buys their reluctance you hear it over
and over it is tough to get customers
today it's got the bubble ruined many
buyers they bought a bunch of stuff and
it didn't work in the company went out
of business and we're still suffering
from that and it's tough economic times
so if somebody's going to buy something
you better solve a real pain that they
want solved and fixed now okay or you
think it's going to be a pain that
they're going to encounter in two years
they just don't know it yet because the
world's changing and eventually this is
going to happen and they're gonna need
to solve this problem an example that
I'm on the board of a company it's taken
longer than I ever we respected that
provides in building wireless coverage
systems for cell phones as LG C Wireless
started to company six years ago on the
belief that eventually people are gonna
want mobile phones to work in buildings
you know like airports and hotels and
convention centers and you know
eventually even business locations
and so the pain we didn't there was then
then that wasn't any pain there was no I
mean people would even think about using
air so they were happy if it worked at
all I didn't drop him on the freeway but
now we found you know six years later
we're getting very large growth
throughout the whole world
now that you've particularly outside of
the US covered the macro you know
environment well did people want to
leave you know everybody carries one
wants it to work wherever they are
except in here so it doesn't have to be
an obvious painkiller today an obvious
pain today but do you foresee one I
prefer the deals at foresee pain
I was a pioneer in the voice messaging
business and when we did voicemail you
can say what pain is solved but the
people you know the initial reaction of
everybody is why would I want a machine
answer the phone
I have secretaries and answer the phone
I have message centers that answer the
phone why do I need a second why do I
need this machine answer the phone I
don't get it and here we are now it's
nobody doesn't have one of those
machines that answer the phone I hate my
contention is by the way a recession
where they had to layoff people and cut
back labor help make the voicemail
industry because suddenly there were no
people answered a phone and customers
were getting aggravated so I guess the
machines okay
if there is technical risk in the
product which is very very very rare
then a prototype or far enough along
that you've reduced the more you reduce
the technical risk the better we will
absolutely fund you with all the
technical was there but it's harder
that's all okay
today's where I I even I started my
company in 1981 and I've put my own
money in my partner's money in and we
believed we build a prototype the VCS
would like us better didn't matter they
liked us because of where we worked and
what we done they didn't need a
prototype they believed we could build
it so in most of the technology you see
today I believe you can build it okay
unless it's you know bending I called
bending physics you know it's something
in the materials area or something or
anywhere just boy that's that's risky I
don't know whether you can bend physics
that far but software or hardware or
design you know I don't need a prototype
the risk is not typically technology in
today's world its market so the more
you've reduced market risk the more
likely you already get funded in today's
world unless it's as I call it bending
physics your unique insights to the
problem this again is part of the team
thing if you come out of a totally
separate area I mean we saw this a lot
in prior years you know the guy was in
some high tech area and decided that
real estate agents needed a website you
know he didn't know a thing about real
estate agents and those things got
funded and they failed so today we
really need domain expertise
particularly in enterprise software
companies you better know that you
better you know you've worked at s AP
and they there's an opportunity an RFID
or some area that they're not working on
and used to god I this is frustrating I
know these customers will I'm gonna
leave and start a company to do this and
develop this kind of software here's an
area so that domain expertise is really
key
you better know I would hope you know
more about it than I do you know if you
don't you know it's hard it's hard again
I'm talking about non real poor
technology deals I'm talk
and software now is not hard to do
sometimes there's some algorithm stuff
but usually it's marketing risk and if
there's marketing risk it's your
understanding of that market that I'm
gonna be looking for your experience
your understanding of that customers
your understanding why they buy and how
does your technology provide a
compelling solution to that problem
obvious this is a tricky one again I
like emerging markets I'm just I I think
you get your home run hits when you go
after a emerging market emerging market
means the problem is going to be there
it's not obvious today but because of
trends in technology like mobile phone
proliferation or proliferation of
storage and an enterprise or
proliferation of email or you know
proliferation of hackers in the internet
there's gonna be a problem I foresee it
you know I just know there will be in
one year two years those usually are a
better opportunity then boy there's a
real problem today with spam I think
I'll start on the anti-spam company with
a slight twist on the technology there's
five guys two years and millions of
dollars ahead of you they could do what
your little idea is once they see you do
it if you got five guys in a garage
writing software it's the barriers are
just not big enough if you're not a
first starter advantage in many areas so
it
so measuring markets is tough I you know
everybody puts they tell you this in
your graduate school put up they're
required and it can you know of data
requests their gardener group chart and
show me how big the markets gonna be in
five years and all that stuff yeah yeah
do it but do it quick because I don't
believe them okay I just don't believe
them
I like to see patents applied for by
startups I don't count them as barriers
I count them as defensive measures i-i-i
ran the patent program and became a real
expert in patents I can get anything
patented today I really can i ike the
patent office is so out of out of out of
it i guess is the right word they're
just so far behind it's so incompetently
staff that they just let patents go
through so when somebody comes in sigh
we've got these three patents of it and
that's you know we're great ok ok that's
nice
you know move on if it's a materials
deal where it is again bending physics
patent protection is very important we
have a fuel cell membrane you know
that's the only protection is passed in
those kinds of deals or fundamental
materials physics chemistry kinds of
stuff in software software patents are
not worth much they're really you can
get them and you do get them because
when the other guy comes after you want
to say you got your patents like oh my
patents you know so I'd encourage you to
get it but I don't see it as a protect
as much of a value except in the bending
physics area no doesn't matter it'll
again only only if it's material stuff
not otherwise and even then it's not you
can come to me with the idea will help
your pie for the patents you don't have
to I gotta I gotta move along here can
you be the market leader this isn't I
tell you the leading market there's
going to be three companies that succeed
in a big market om e voicemail had
happened most big markets there's three
guys the first guy does a really great
and the last to do okay I was number two
so I know this so being leaders great
Canyon well you get another run away to
create that kind of a company you know
in biotech your your is chemistry and
physics and you know all that stuff yeah
either you you have an existing problem
where your product is better there is
the equivalent in the IT world is I call
a cheaper faster smaller okay with
Moore's law I could always go build the
next gigabit hunter gigabit megabyte or
router and it's going to be better than
the one
designed for years ago by Cisco because
I used the latest chips it's going to be
cheaper it's going to be faster it's
gonna be so those are similar
opportunities in biotech yeah this is
important to show me you understand your
customers and your customers customers
do you know will you you know the buyers
not only is most of the time not the
user of a product you know there's a
particularly when you're selling to
corporations or service providers you
know the buyer is not the guys gonna
make the decision to write the check
it's not always a user sometimes it is
but many times it isn't do you
understand that how much time they'll
spend with it you can read these this is
this is just to get you to really think
hard and you know I do this now when I
look at the deal what what what how does
this affect the people that buy it use
it sell it whatever they're gonna do
with it launch a service with it I
really want you to understand I
understand them and understand how they
live competitors I don't know how many
times I've been pitched and as so
competitors we don't have any let's see
so that means nobody's writing checks
for what you sell right there's not
there's no money being spent for the
problem you say you solve okay there's
just none people just live with a
problem and they spend no money to solve
it okay sure so it doesn't mean I don't
mean to say a competitor that does what
you do I mean the competitor for those
funds okay that's what I'm looking for
you know or who could be a competitor
for those funds if they see what you're
doing
show me you understand that are they
Giants or are they other startups you'll
have done your homework if you have if I
know the five competitors and you don't
know them because I've spent more time
looking at it I'll you know go away I'm
sorry you should be doing that there are
always three other groups if it's a good
my favorite saying is if it's a good I
if you're not followed
if there isn't a follower it's not a
good idea okay it's not a big enough
market it doesn't invite competition it
can't be a big market it's can
yes yeah you know I mean if I was in if
I had been sitting in the Netscape
presentation my question would have been
well who will be competitors what about
Microsoft you know might they go do this
when they see what you're doing what
would they do to kill you you know I
don't next gate was a financial success
in a company failure really because it
went out of business
you know miserably so and their
technology doesn't exist in the world to
speak of anymore so you know they got
killed by Microsoft in the end they were
lucky enough to get out get public in a
frothy market and you know pay back for
their employees there are baddest
bouncers but it's a company it doesn't
exist anymore so I don't consider I
don't
I consider that a financial success but
not a business success so if there the
question it to them would have been what
about Microsoft you know and yeah what
are we gonna do and they didn't I don't
think they handled that well when
Microsoft came out with the there were I
don't think they did as good a job as
they might happen they'd admit that
competitors we talked about that this
was very important it's not easy to do
by the way at all how much total money
will you need we're gonna fund you an
initial round of money say five million
between us and another VC that's a
typical around these days is five
million dollars five to six million if
you need more to reach a meaningful
milestone it's gonna be tough you better
be one awesome team if you need eight to
ten in an a round because what you're
doing takes that much to get to the next
meaningful milestone then you better be
an awesome team okay otherwise you know
five to six feels about right to me and
that's about what we're doing very
early-stage we'll put in a million half
a million to you know two million maybe
a round where you're gonna build a
product and get some customer feedback
and traction with it you know
betas five to six feels about right but
if it doesn't do it don't don't mislead
me don't lie again be brutally honest
with yourself because as you'll see
later if you run out of money and you
haven't got a real meaningful milestone
that next round is not going to be much
fun
not in today's market unfortunately it's
it's hard you're gonna give up 50 to 60%
of the company for this five to six
million okay if you need it we don't we
want you guys incentivize so even if you
raise ten million you're gonna give up
fifty to sixty percent of the company
but I don't want to write a five million
dollar check for twenty five percent
ownership okay that's just expensive in
terms of the exits and their you know
although numbers so I'm generalizing
here we've done a rounds with raising
ten million and you know or twelve
million we did one but it you know it
better be something we see a huge upside
opportunity
it's very it's it's tricky if we're the
first to see it we like it we will lead
and introduce you to others and the same
with our brethren okay you will be out
there talking to multiple VCS you have
your you have a choice of either you try
to put together the syndicate or pick
one of them to put together to syndicate
okay it's really your you should you
should manage that if you can i I'm HAP
I'm gonna syndicate some pcs will not so
when I meet an entrepreneur and I like
the idea I'll ask who else you talk to
oh yeah we like working with them let
them know we're interested
either way as long as the other VC is
one we like and respect to work with so
you should check with your VC where if
we one of them is going to lead and say
we get the right to accept the other co
investor so you better make sure it's
top tier or good VCS that you're trying
to put together the better the team
obviously I talked about this cheaper
the money you need a financing plan just
like you need to develop playing again
don't run out of money without reaching
a meeting from milestone now what do I
mean by a meaningful milestone it's very
frustrating to me meaningful milestone
for be round used to be a good team in
place implementing a good product it
didn't mean customers today
unfortunately I if I'm gonna look at a
be deal I want to talk to prospects that
know what you're doing or customers or
betas so unfortunately in today's world
to get a reasonable valuation and a B
you need some market feedback that
customers like the pain you're solving
it will pay your dollars for it this is
not easy okay
it's tricky so don't run out of money in
today's world without having so don't
over engineer the product don't I mean
this is why you this is why it's hard to
get equipment deal done these days it is
very difficult to do an equipment deal
and get a thing out to customers for
five million bucks I know that okay it's
hard so you got to figure out how to
build something in today's world for
that amount of money
six million maybe seven if you push me
that gets you and devise an engineering
plan that gets prototypes you know early
units in the hands of prospects it
doesn't need to be you know that they've
used it for weeks and months it but
they've I can call them and say what do
you think of this know this is a great
biggest thing it solves my problem I
love it
these guys are great that's what I'd
like to hear
you're bound to slip engineering
schedules so you know sue I always
assumed a three-month slip whenever I do
engineering schedules so I know I'm not
making this easy for you so I'm telling
you to raise less money but meet assumed
a slip and reap meaningful milestones
hey if it was easy everybody would do it
and then obviously if you miss your plan
it can be we don't a ban on at a round
company for missing a milestone in my
memory okay we have not so it's not that
you will be put out of business it's
that you will own less of the company
when it is successful hopefully or what
is successful that's what it means exit
strategy
you know I write what I tell people and
exit I'm gonna you know when if somebody
when a venture capitalist oh what's your
exit strategy don't tell them I plan to
get bought by Cisco my plan is to get
bought by Merck my plan is to get bought
by don't tell them that my plan is to
build a fast-growing profitable company
and then see what you know if the mut
public markets there I'll go public and
it's not I think someone of these three
guys would be interested in buying me
that's the answer period okay do not say
I'm what I'm looking for is who might
buy you because most exits are
acquisitions today but I want you know
the best way to get bought and not sold
is fast growing profitable company it's
amazing you know I I tell all my my CEOs
you know going public isn't the best day
of your life getting funded by the VCS
isn't the best day of your business life
being profitable and never having to
talk to a venture capitalist again is
going to be the best day of your life
I've been through that believe me it is
okay
yeah profitable
they'll present I'm not talking about
know they'll presented playing at
profitability but they'll they won't
live toward it you know one of the
frustrating things if you get your money
easily you spend it foolishly it's just
human nature i-i've been in be rounds of
my own companies where it got hot
you know frothy and they a twenty five
million dollars when they only were
gonna raise ten of the price was high
and I can I gotta take away fifteen and
put it away you can't have it I could
not stop them from wasting money it's
just sitting there in the bank and no we
can go do this and we can do that and
they wasted five million of the money
they mean is no now they'll admit it no
you were right we shouldn't you know so
people complain about how hard it is to
raise money and I tell them we make it
hard so you'll spend it carefully it's a
different point
I'm getting paid for my my I'm getting
paid for my time as much as my money so
when I do a board seat and I help a
company it uses up a slot and I don't
have that many of them all of us are the
same way and we want to own twenty to
twenty-five percent of your company when
it's liquid okay
by the time it you know it's almost
inevitable by the time you are liquid
and you go public employees will own 25
percent of the company that are there at
the time and the investors will own
seventy five through three rounds of
funding the numbers just work out that
way you give up half then you give up
another thirty percent then you give up
another 25 20 to 25 percent and the C
round this is assuming everything goes
well even if it doesn't go well we're
gonna make sure we improve we add to the
stock option pool so the employees that
are there when this company's liquid own
25 percent at least of the company so
don't worry about what you get in the
first round do not worry about it
you should try to get as much money as
possible yeah yeah absolutely the money
amount you raise is to get to a
meaningful milestone but yes I mean we
do I see it now now I saw a deal
recently where they raised two million
seed and the VC took forty percent so am
I really gonna take half the company for
a million dollars not likely but we have
you know we have I don't I think it's a
little greedy but it's been die seeing
it done
you
we want to see a hundred-million exit at
least because we're gonna own the
numbers are easy we want to make five
times our money okay if I put in take
half your company if I take twenty five
or twenty five percent of your company
for for two and a half million bucks you
know when you if you're worth 100
million I own twenty five percent twenty
five million that's a ten times return
that'd be great
and of course I'm gonna put two and a
half then you're gonna need to be around
where I put another two and a half so
now I got five million in so that's so
five times return you're not gonna make
it on the first two and a half that I
put it now again I'm talking about - he
sees he's putting in two and a half and
then another round another five or eight
or whatever it is so our goal is to make
five times and you know on average ten
would be great
they're hard yeah
yeah I have run into conflict we talk
about it a lot and they usually give in
although no I will tell you the truth if
is if the founders are needed to run the
business they get the sake I don't if
they're not needed you know they say
look if the man let me phrase it this
way if the management team running the
company says we want to sell now what am
I gonna do say no run the company is
slavery you know no keep running it okay
I have had cases of founders who are not
the management team who would like to
take it and run but the management team
wants to keep going then the founders
lose okay but literally a good
management team that says we just don't
think this is gonna scale it's time we
did it my company we build like you know
Pat my partner I had a hundred million
or twenty million of revenue we felt the
market you know we're public it was
getting tough with time to do a merger
you know time to go join somebody else's
bandwagon we merged with octi so it's
really the management team say not the
founders unless they're the management
team
today I think liquidity events are five
to seven years in the real world I'd
love it to be three but that's not
realistic and by the way that's
something you guys got to realize it's
not let me do a start-up and I'll be
rich in three years okay it took me 15
years personally so it it's not that
fast so I want you that committed to
this endeavor for you know a good a good
liquidity event is is really you know
profitability growing or public is going
to take five years at least in today's
world
there's too many variables I suspect to
really I'm sure there's plenty of
Harvard guys who've studied it that's a
it's it's got I mean I've looked at a
lot of exits and when they were done and
some were done you know at the peak and
some were done on the bottom and it's
really the judgment of you guys running
that business every day should make that
call I mean I was involved with all some
of you're old enough to remember that it
was sold IBM and boy it was at the peak
I mean but I've seen like Netscape was
sold on AOL that toward the decline I
mean I mean you hear stories and talking
to some guys now god we got an offer of
four hundred million dollars you know
three years ago to sell a company and
now we're gonna be bankrupt you know so
it's really you guys who run that
business every day should be making that
call not me I come to board meetings
once a month or once a quarter you're
there every day running the business you
better make better have enough
visibility of your world and how you're
growing or not growing to make that call
you don't have to have a CEO to get
funded okay you gotta have a leader some
amount of leadership somebody to build a
team around I don't care if it's a
brilliant technologist but somebody
around which we can build a team but
most deals today come to us with
somebody who says they're going to be
the CEO
you know the founder says I think I can
be the CEO I'm willing to give almost
almost any founder not everyone almost
any founder a chance we have seen deals
where the guy founder came in on the CEO
I said I'm sorry I'm not gonna fund you
as a CEO you don't know any you've never
managed anybody in your life you've been
a great technologist in the lab or in
developing products back in Cisco but
you never you don't have a management
bone in your body how can you be the CEO
of this company
and if they don't agree to that and I'm
not gonna fund you but it is it that you
know again the better the CEO that you
come in with more likely you are to get
funded the better the leadership but we
will absolutely fund first-time
entrepreneurs who have management
experience usually the best CEOs I will
be honest with you I think come out of a
marketing background not pure technical
they've done something in marketing
because again the risk is not technology
the risk
is the market so most of the time you
want leadership in a company most of the
time not always that has strong
understanding of the problems of
acquiring profitably acquiring customers
this is the puzzle in business today how
do i how do i acquire customers
profitably that's what's hard today
we have a whole stable of CEOs VPS of
marketing business got people that we
will absolutely say why don't you join
hands with this young entrepreneur and
see if you think you want to go build a
company around this idea I didn't
understand the questions marketing
background
I don't like oh I see I don't like it I
call it the I do not want a one hop from
HP IBM Oracle CEO one-hot means they
just left IBM or HP or some other large
company or Microsoft and it was decided
to do a start-up CEO they do not usually
succeed on their first job out it can be
very successful in their second so to me
the best CEO I'll talk about that in a
minute
best CEO hasn't done it before started a
company or a VP of Marketing or you know
some position but has the
entrepreneurial experience the big
company guys are not they expect
somebody to you know take care of buying
paper clips and you know where's the you
know where's the limo and you know I
mean it's so their brain the other the
real the reality is when you work for HP
IBM your brand sells you don't have to
scrap you don't have to be scrappy to
sell I mean I tell you it was a shock to
me when I started calling people and
they'd say who the hell are you after I
worked at a large company I mean it's
like you know you know you call them is
so so calling from IBM or people pay
attention and so and so it's all calling
from you know ABC startup it's like who
are you and an executives these guys
really get there you know they just
don't get it if they've never done it
before
so second hop I like those guys they
learned okay you really learned the hard
way by the first hop no so markets are
important people and products so
actually the order should be people
markets and product in terms of priority
a great team in a big fast-growing
market will figure out how to make us
money is the same okay so it should be
the order should be people markets
and product and it's very hard for
engineers to accept product as last hum
as an engineer so if I can I can tell
you that I was engineer I started a
company I absolutely felt I had this
brilliant idea I never world would beat
a path to my door and hired a guy that
I'd work with it Rome to be my VP of
marketing and sales and it was a failure
my first product was absolute failure
because it first of all a guy I hired
was not a marketing guy he was a sales
guy he didn't have a clue how to figure
out what people would really buy and
what they pay for it and you know
there's a that's another lecture on
diversity marketing in sales but people
markets and then product now I forgot to
give attribute this is a graph we had
you know McBaine McKinsey or whatever
they're called through this study I
think was McBaine quest something or
other and you know by the way the way to
tell a graph but I get see graphs shown
to me if it's a marketing slide there's
nothing on the axis
you know the marketing guys don't don't
they don't put things on the axes
engineers you know always have to put
things on the axis so being an engineer
I had to put something on the axis okay
to say team quality so this is a
measurement of the quality of the team
and the probability of getting funded
but then of course you want to ask how
did I come up with these data points or
all looking ahead here it makes a joke a
little harder okay the first one is if
you're you know two Harvard MBAs with no
work experience come to us with a you
know a real estate website plan they're
not going to get fun it's just it's very
I mean we wouldn't fund it now if it was
two Stanford MBAs it's a higher
probability
of course it's much little more likely I
think we're up to 15 percent likely that
will get funded but it's you know it's
possible a brilliant engineer this is
the brilliant engineer out of IBM or the
brilliant engineer out of SR I or the
brilliant engineer
they're a problem they they know how to
make it work once they may they're not
on to this you need a brilliant engineer
with entrepreneurial experience is much
more likely to succeed again the big
company guys you know how long it takes
IBM to develop a new product compared to
what a startup should you know do it's
it's like three times longer because of
this and they got overhead and people to
do this for them and that you know very
different it is the CEO of two prior
fail he's learned something okay and
maybe they've learned enough that this
will be their third success I don't I
don't i'd actually would have put this
this one up above 50% but the McBaine
McKinsey thing came down with lower in
their study but I would have given more
credit for yeah you learn more by your
mistakes you learn more by what you do
wrong and by having it be easily done
right I believe in life so when you make
mistakes they hurt and you learn when
you do something right you don't know
what you did right it just happened you
know you're successful so I like bad
experiences for from my management team
I like them to have learned be a little
humble and understand you know so with
these guys what did you learn what you
do wrong what are you do different
highly recommended brilliant
technologist we've talked about this one
yeah will absolutely look for these
people and we'll build a company around
them
brilliant we're not use the word
technologist I use it interchangeably
with engineer an engineer is the
technologist when they invent something
the brilliant year with no
entrepreneurial experience is less
likely there this is one out of IBM you
know you worked at IBM research for 25
years and has come up with an idea we've
done is we've asked our eye researchers
boy it's hard they build it they just
it's tough to get that technology you
got technology that has to become a
product that has to become a business it
has to be you know so most
entrepreneurial technologists or
engineers know what a product is as
opposed to just technology so maybe I
should have said a brilliant engineer
there that's like you're right good
correction his question if the risk to
your business is the product the more
risks you've eliminated the better it is
for getting funded but I don't believe
that many most cases most cases our
product risk yes then then yeah I will
tell you what would help there even if
you don't have the product if you've
gone out and talked to five of them
because you've worked for so-and-so who
and you know these people because you
worked at Oracle or you worked at
Seybold your work and you know the
coca-cola and you know the CIO and
you've talked to them you talk to them
about what you're doing and they boy is
great you say could you you might be a
reference for a VCS to call you and they
sure and I call them and they say we
really like this idea here's the paint
that's good enough we call it it is one
of the processes we encourage our early
phase startups to do is immediately put
together a PowerPoint pitches talk to
customers immediately well your
engineers are developing the rest of the
company is out there talking to
prospects about fine-tuning the user
interface and what features are gonna
have it released one and so and and then
by the time you're ready for beta you've
talked to 50
customers that became five betas so one
of the processes we encourage once we
fund is absolutely getting out there
with before you've written one line of
code is you've got a pitch to prospects
on what you're doing and they're giving
you a feedback and there's that's not
hard to do
it sounds like god I got a call on a guy
and tell them we we have a network of
these guys they're CIOs love looking at
technology and what could talk an early
stage and some of them like trialing it
and we have not had a problem for our
companies we fund getting them
introductions and getting them I see a
meeting with prospective customers
if it's really a I use the term bending
physics if it's really hard for somebody
to believe this could work
yeah it can help although I don't want
technology risk and market risk in a
deal
I'll take technology risk and fund it
I'll take market risk and fund it but I
don't like doing both so if you've got
technology risk boy you better be an
obvious big market you're you're
disruptive in you can you know it's by
how long they've been around you know if
you've been around ten years plus you're
gonna be around if you've only been
around five years or less you started in
the bubble I'd be nervous so it's how
long they've been around and been at it
if you if you survive through three you
know through beginning before the bubble
you were around through the bubble raise
money after you're gonna be around let
me let me let me keep going I'm running
only got ten minutes left so let me get
through this and then last one has it
done it before CEO so criteria again I
think I've emphasized this domain
expertise I want you to know more about
this and the customers and the
technology and than anybody in the world
I want the 18min I want the experts
nothing more to say they're the
innovative business model one is a
tricky one you do need distribution you
do need partners you need something you
just can't it's hard to just say I'm
gonna go start a company I'm gonna sell
direct to the Fortune 1000 and
everything will be good it's harder
these days so models where you know I
think EMC will be interested in
partnering with here and HP on it you
know getting the credibility of how you
do that I can talk about it as I get
another lecture of going to market with
partners is a real plus in today's world
so that's what I mean about innovative
models not around the technology but
around how are you going to market can
help okay how do you make a good
presentation
this one's follow the rules of good
presentations you haven't taken a class
take a class don't read your slides
there I am reading the slides
qualify your audience stand up and
present we will try to pull you off
track
we absolutely most species are I mean I
it's embarrassing sometimes how they
will ask questions that are not relevant
at my partner why is you asking that now
your best if you're going to answer the
question say I'll get to you you know
don't let them pull you off track it's
it's almost a contest in some guys do
this you know let me see if I can get
this guy you know a little bit crazy by
and see how well he handles it I think
they're doing I don't know but I'll ask
a question I see you're doing something
and I'm perfectly I'll get to that later
I'll cover that that's fine if you're
not going to cover it you know give a
brief answer but try not to let a wrong
if I don't answer your question later
you know they'll usually forget the
question by the way can we come back to
that but keep to your pitch as much as
you can tell me what you do in the first
three minutes please okay tell me what
pain you solve and why you and how it's
unique in the first three minutes you
know this is the elevator pitch thing
give it to me
in the first three minutes don't yeah I
want your introductions I want to know
who you are
but I want to know what you do because
everything else flies flowing it's
amazing they teach you I think they must
teach you here Harvard probably teaches
this tell them about the market first
tell me how big the market is you know
that's the first thing you got to talk
about it doesn't do me any good for you
to be telling me how big the market I
have no idea what you do or what what to
think about that market as I'm thinking
about is you're telling me about it so
tell me what you do and then tell me
about the rest people introductions
relevant facts only I just can't tell
you how often people get go overboard
and take up time about themselves in
their team it's important but I can read
and I want to know why you I want to
know why you are uniquely qualified to
do this that's what I care about I spent
four years at sa P and while I was there
I realized this problem and I talk to
these customers and here's what I
learned I managed the development I want
to know about you it's relevant to what
you're doing
relevant market information only and be
brief this is the usual required
McKinsey data quest chart of how big the
market is in the next five years fine
put it up there but go through it
quickly be prepared to go into
reasonable death on the products
technology fast some of us are more
technical than other VCS I have had too
many presentations where the guys were
not prepared to talk about the
technology and that's a mistake
ok this this hurried at you next next
next I want to get to the technology I
want to know what you're doing uniquely
in technology I am a technologist so I I
care about the market I care about the
people and I can okay I got a pain there
how do you solve it how do you do that
you know and I did one recently where
the guy the CEO presenting literally
could not answer very simple questions
about the product in a matter of fact he
answered some of them wrong and that's a
real mistake so he set up a conference
call with their technologists a couple
weeks later when I found out how they
really did it it wasn't that complicated
you should have been able to pitch it
it's recoverable but it is harder it's
it's absolutely I won't say it isn't
it's it then it depending on all some
team what I when I see a deal come in I
can tell you the quality of the
investors by the quality of the team I
got to tell you it not one-to-one but
almost one-to-one Maps when I see a be
round and and it's you know God what
does this see you know they brought in
to see yeah because that's the
difference typically is the the crappy
investors don't work the team issues
that's typically the difference so if I
was gonna in only could get funded by
crappy investors I do my damnedest
problem is good people want to join
ventures funded by good companies so it
ain't easy I want to see financials by
corner till profitable then out three to
five years annually so I want to know
how big it can be but I want to see
financials by quarter I want to see cash
burn I want a seat when you need to
raise more money I don't want to see
what milestones you're gonna make as to
product and customers until your
profitable funding milestones at Solan I
want is that this is very important a
lot of guys leave this out I need to
know how much money you're gonna raise
when you're gonna raise it and how big
you think you can be I I am a I'm a
numbers I learned to be a financial
numbers guy the hard way by be involved
in public companies I mean you learn to
pay attention to your numbers so I am
very good at looking at you know an
income statement and telling you whether
the numbers make sense in terms of what
your sales costs are and you're sick you
know how caught you know so your
assumptions on how fast your ramp up
sales I can I can look at it now or god
that doesn't make any sense
there's no way you're gonna ramp revenue
that much with that few salespeople it's
spending that little and mark as is this
doesn't match the industry so make sure
you've thought about it and looked at
comparables and you know got some
information it's all available these
days on the Internet be aware of time
seeing a lot of guys run out of that
hour be aware if we like you we'll let
you go over 15 to 20 slides seem way too
many slides for an hour pitch
there's been an hour and 15 minutes we
got three minutes left I have 22 slides
after you here you what happens to next
bad signs this is my famous one after
hearing your pitch the VC says I'll
think about it and get back to you
there's a Japanese expression I think
it's Kentish mas right and it means so
it says I'll think about it
it's a polite way Japanese saying no
Japanese don't like to say no so they
say I'll think about it be Caesar I wish
I could say it's cuz they're polite it's
usually because they don't have an
opinion or a feeling or they don't know
what to say they might miss a hot deal
or they say I'll think about it
don't let him get away with I'll think
about it okay if they say thank you very
much for a presentation I'll think about
it say what do you mean you think about
it what do you think about what does
that mean you know what more information
do you need when can I expect to hear
back what else can I do to help you
think about it yeah don't let him get
away with a thing about or you know are
you really telling me no and you're just
wearing polite be blunt it's okay
it's just often so with my partners it's
another polite way of saying you know
God I haven't any idea what is a good
idea or not maybe somebody else will
you never hear back after calling
repeatedly I returned i when I walked
into Mayfield I said I'm not gonna treat
them the way they treated me my third
round was hell I've met every venture
capitalist in the country raising money
and fortunately in those days there's
only 50 of them okay and I got more I'll
think about it sand no return phone
calls so I don't do that but most VCS
will not bother to get back to you if
the answer is no good signs you could
ask for due diligence information you
know okay I like this
give me your due diligence list have it
ready you know or email it to me that's
okay you know references customer
references personal references that's
what I'm looking for technology
references of its technology deal you
could ask for detailed business plan you
could ask to pitch to more partners you
get sent away to do more work that's not
always a bad sign you know gosh this is
interesting but I really need you to
talk to these three customers or these
you know come back when you it's not a
bad sign you eventually get to present
at the partners meeting
what do you get besides money our number
one job I feel is to put together a
great team
and to help you do that
I interview all executive hires we have
board meetings once a week where you get
to hear me tell you what you're doing
wrong or right as well as the other
board members I do a lot of CEO
mentoring talk to my CEOs usually once a
week I do replace CEOs is needed again
that's the board's number one financial
response the padishah nari
responsibility is replaced CEO we use
our network to help in all these areas
and we provide follow-on financing
health as needed
in our firm two passionate partners can
get a deal done even if the rest think
it's so-so
yes but they better be really passionate
and want to get it done some
partnerships require one guy can veto
one managing partner can veto we don't
work that way so it depends there is it
is not easy if you have two or three
really opposed that'd be hard
it can be anywhere from again before
you've spent any money if you're a great
people if you're a great team it can be
anywhere from that to you not quite so
and you've done a lot of work with
customers and you've validated the
market then but again most engineers
instinct is build prototype I don't care
unless again I emphasize its market risk
I most of the time nervous about so you
can go to cuss the prospects with
PowerPoint this is what I'm going to
build would you buy it that's enough for
me in most species but team is the
number one
they're working on technology they're
now working on products a start-up can
always be a large company to market if
they start well before yeah at the same
time that large company realizes the
opportunity I wouldn't go up against
Intel frankly they're awesome
I will not go up against Intel in any
market IBM I'll go up against because
they're slow moving but Intel I would
not go up against and Microsoft would
scare the hell allowed me to go up
against so it depends on who they are no
I'm worried about the time to market if
we can get to market you're ahead of
them fine and by the way if we had too
much market had a year ahead of IBM and
a technology they're interested they go
out to people saw it's going to need it
Oracle is going to need it BA is gonna
need it so that's fine that IBM comes
out with it as long as you're ahead I'm
not I don't worry about that
I don't worry about other big companies
coming after startups on patents the
only go you'll have you know that's
that's what's so rare I don't typically
worry about an in software area in
biotech it's a bigger issue
no you get it getting them getting am
indicate you know getting them these
guys will join if I get funded great if
you can do it but again I'm looking for
that one person at least on the founding
team that I can use to attract you know
if I fund it that really attracts talent
I don't want to I want some passionate
BPM marketing business development
technologist I don't care what it is but
that person I can't be I can't be the
recruiter you know only it's got to be
something that they're doing that
attracts this team more than just the
fact that may feel funded it